here's a tricky test question the
letters d g i iint can be used to form
five letter strings as d-i-g-i-t or DG
IIT using these letters how many five
letter strings can be formed in which
the two occurrences of the letter I are
separated by at least one other letter
we'll start out with dgiit and count the
total number of ways it can be arranged
we have five letters which would be five
factorial but the eyes repeat so we need
to divide by two factorial giving 60
ways now let's consider DG double i t
this is where the two eyes are together
these are four objects that can be
arranged in 4 factorial or 24 Ways if we
take the total minus the number of ways
the eyes are together that gives the
number of ways the eyes are not together
and that'll be 60 minus 24 giving the
answer of 36 ways